how's it going breasts but it's beautifu
and welcome to doorways this is a pretty
beta special special version that the
developers were nice enough to let me
play the intro of the game it's a new
horror game it has a greenlight page so
if you're interested in this afterwards
go ahead and check that out help them
out and it looks pretty awesome I don't
know too much about it but I know enough
to know that it looks creepy as [ __ ]
hell just by looking at the intro screen
honestly enough chitchat
let's just play oh yeah it has the it
has the voice actor of Alexander in
amnesia and he's pretty hot I mean he
has a good voice I mean I have no I
don't we've been assigned some cases ok
Psychopaths must be found ah
the other agents couldn't get them why
not but how I can do it no I don't think
whoa it looks pretty awesome I'm just
excited to play a horror game with an
actual story like it's been a while all
right what do we got controls go forward
I already figured that out obviously
jump space Crouch slow pool interact ok
oh these are the guys I made it
ok that's cool I guess we're trapped
here did we come from there where the
hell are we come from uh ok well I guess
we go down the creepy corridor huh oh do
you knew I was coming didn't yet oh you
too
you tell your friends don't you son of a
[ __ ] oh I bet there's bad things
beyond that door
what is that the journey will not begin
until you already what do you need a box
to keep valuable objects a place to look
at notes uh-huh and a bag to put tools
what was that
okay well I guess I gotta find them
oh how did they know I'm coming oh you
bros go far so now I'll be right there
that's not how it works what do you know
about games more than me probably god
damn it
okay uh hello I just want a little box
so I can put things I forgot to bring a
backpack and my lunch box what are you
how do you there's no oil how do you
flame anyway it's got them wizard things
oh there's something here
what is that crutch to go through narrow
paths holding down see okay I'm a
[ __ ] genius I'm a goddamn genius
whole miles of rockets to attract them
focus okay Jennifer what are you hiding
from I don't know what to do oh maybe
I'm supposed to look underneath all the
stones there's a lot of them here we go
JT has paid strike that's a relics are
what the hell did I just do
whoa what the what the [ __ ] are you
doing
get away from my game what do you want
look at my genitals well I'm not oh [ __ ]
he went inside me how is that even
possible
okay well we found something maybe we
should put it on that other thing what
are you resting I think he really wants
to we're going back I don't even know
what this is correct
oh it sounds not oh it clothes didn't eh
Oh solid out of our [ __ ] god damn it
we're [ __ ] is it stuff down there what
are we going oh you open oh wait did we
come from here my dad [ __ ] no I'm
not hallelu hallelujah what am I doing
here anyway seriously
okay what do you move forward and jump
at the same time
well I knew that Jesus Christ all right
we got our notes we press n to open the
notes no problem
I like that very cool a little designer
or whatever yep
it feels like we're in the Hades the
underground or some [ __ ] like that and I
don't really want to go there no no I
shouldn't have to go there if I don't
want to now we just need the last object
which is probably in the other one see
I'm not even afraid anymore because I'm
so [ __ ] smart and [ __ ] ha ha
this game is a no-brainer it took me a
long time I added it a lot good ok what
do we got
oh ok what do you want make your own way
to get to the top oh that's interesting
I'm a pursue sir I'm a pursue girl I
know how high I can jump though can
either the Crouch jump I can do the
Crouch jump ok
I wasn't that too difficult and we have
our items alright that's a pretty pretty
cool way to introduce the the aspects of
the game so to say but I think we're
done here I think we're ready to start
now please you bros ready for this [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
why what okay I find all the items all
you need check your inventory and find a
way to pass through the door oh [ __ ]
what is that oh whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
hello anyone home hello a note for me
that's so nice there are things which
are burned into my memory my name is
Thomas foster again and my duty is to
bring these four Psychopaths to justice
I just hope to resist their sadistic
influences their corrupted Minds could
overpower my own and find them I must
cool oh snap I'll snap the death door
closed after it god damn it
hi four people okay it's loading screen
isn't it I can't see [ __ ] I felt like
this is like amnesia it's gonna take a
while for [ __ ] to actually the forest of
snakes is that the name of the first
chapter coz this doesn't look like a
forest to me or maybe this but god damn
its starak what was like [ __ ] oh come on
what is how what is happening what am i
doing with my life
I've get so [ __ ] dark I could odd
jeez I can I can barely see what I'm
doing okay we're I I don't know how I
missed this but there was an auteur now
I've been walking around for like five
cubes London England 1962 professor of
history suspected for the kidnapping of
17 people and he listened eyes in the
adjoining areas of a cabin owned by his
family the missing persons have in
common
certain indirect factors religions or
pagan practices for a nationality that
are not reason enough for the local
police to start an investigation
doorways link the profiles of the
victims to the topics in which professor
Gibbs specializes okay well I'm gonna
keep that because I like his picture
he's a very handsome man oh [ __ ]
there we go there we go we're fine hey
hey okay
well we're not dead yet and there's
another note there oh oh oh what was
that did I blink blinking is never
getting her again what it says hello I'd
arrived at the crossroads I knew I had
to keep going and follow his steps if I
wanted to find the professor but I found
something about the place absolutely
terrifying oh [ __ ] no no whoa no I think
nothing absolutely terrifying I felt
trapped obsessed by those dark Beals
bales and I knew that I wouldn't be able
to stand a single minute lost in the
darkness I need to find a light source
as soon as possible so I guess it
borrows a lot from amnesia with a light
I guess so I can't go out of my own oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I don't want to go out of
my own anyway
[ __ ] you darkness okay we need a light
source how about here
hello please don't kill me I'm a regular
mine on a quest to get the [ __ ] out of
this place oh wow hello can we carry it
[ __ ] yeah we're gonna carry that oh okay
so it's old so wait wait wait we we take
this and then we lit it up yeah big on
demons dark creatures of the night big
ah oh where did it go
Oh goddamnit you can't jump can you I'll
snap oh [ __ ] okay
flame on flame on [ __ ] that's right
that's right
be gone yeah you're not so cool Oh doggy
boy mother food get out of the darkness
and illumination that was [ __ ] creepy
as hell okay we're gonna keep you're my
new best friend your name will be Enrico
and wrinkle you like the pattern let it
go where do we go now we're not coming
eh yeah we're going here what about this
physics secret ah Rico for [ __ ] sake
flame on Enrico the god demon [ __ ] be
gone demon [ __ ] it really runs out
fast and it's like uh a guy Rico
Illuminati and Rico I mean it nothing
okay where the [ __ ] are we this [ __ ] did
not help in Tikal okay we're going here
oh oh oh the [ __ ] after me the
[ __ ] after me that's okay
[ __ ] are after me all the time
hi who wants the [ __ ] now UN Rica where
the hell are we
another lie okay again I'm taking you at
that moment I felt I was retracing the
steps of many others like me how did
they overcome the mortal chill that
lurks in the darkness their souls went
astray and got lost forever in the
shadows ah because there was another
horror that scared them even more that
made them flee into the dark woods they
fled the place I'm entering wait the
monsters are scared of what I'm going to
own well that just means we're [ __ ]
doesn't know that it isn't I right
Enrico alright holy [ __ ] we're so Oh
what the [ __ ]
this a nightmare I believe your [ __ ]
died God did he [ __ ] sucks man Wow
this [ __ ] oh come on I can't reach it
Enrico come on don't be a [ __ ] Enrico
god damnit yes flame on
Oh what is this place oh this looks
creepy hey let's party
you guys wanna oh [ __ ] do you hate me
and Rico don't you okay just don't look
that don't look down I tell you I'm fine
alright fine this place is wonderful it
has magic and mysteries I don't know
where the [ __ ] were entering oh that
sounds great
it's like we're entering hell or some
[ __ ] like that
that's not no big deal I've been in
worse places now that's not appropriate
now woody are we gonna keep going
wonderful oh this way oh don't you again
no bad girl uh hey there little lady
I guess you're lost huh anybody think
I'm also but I I mean honey I need to go
wait by it right okay I'm done wait I'm
just gonna come closer
yeah and we go it weren't you okay hider
okay never okay maybe if I go dr.
Burgess
[ __ ] another way but she was so hot
okay well excuse me princess genius poot
strikes again
stupid [ __ ] I was easy
idiot idiot
oh alright we going we're going here
it's like we entered like a lost city or
some [ __ ] like oh [ __ ] what happened oh
and the Ricoh that [ __ ] [ __ ] wait
I'm not going backwards am I now we're
good Oh
time to run oh great now we're trapped
here in this [ __ ] nightmare baby do
okay later I get it I get it you like
you like to stand places hangout
no problem I won't get in your [ __ ] if
you don't get in my [ __ ] great no
problem no problemo
well I guess this is it huh I guess the
only appropriate thing to say is I was
gonna say Yolo but that's too obvious I
guess your anima that did not work ok
another noun cool hahahahahahaha Rover's
Regina I love that I can't wait for this
game to actually be out this is just the
first beginning or whatever you can go
to green-light to vote for it if it's
something you you think look interesting
I think this looks really interesting I
think they're yeah they did a great job
in building tensions
so that made me want more you know I'm a
little sad it's over here
but anyway I press I hope you enjoyed
watching let me know and leave a like if
you want me to play the full version
winners out and I'll be sure to do that
anyway I'll see in the next one
sales a birthday my dear what is not
dealers